he'll be like he'll he'll be like we'll
be like you cheated on me and he's like
you're just on your feet
no but
are you telling me as a man right
there's no argument we can have this to
say that you're in your period just calm
[ __ ] down
that we've been with you for a prolonged
period of time and we can see your your
behavior changing at a certain point in
time
right they know your cycle
are you telling me that that's never an
argument for us no look at me yes you
already know
first of all you already know crazy as
hell
i'm crazy
by saying that that pisses the girl off
mm-hmm
why would you want to do that again
because he's not trying to piss you off
okay but then if you already know by
saying that it pisses her off yeah but
why would you like but why
she's trying to like you know it just
makes her feel like what i'm saying if
you have a conversation and he's saying
like no i legitimately like this is i
think it's because you're on your period
i'm not trying to offend you right and
you have that information getting upset
is a choice
it's a choice
if men say forget me if men say that
they're wondering
so are now your feelings
logical
right
supposed to trump
his feelings
because
right but what it is is that if he's at
the receiving end
of your feelings
women can do all kinds of stuff right
if i'm at the receiving end of your
feelings
and i'm like
hang on a minute she's only doing this
because
she's and i'm thinking this yeah
i'm gonna say but if you are being more
emotional and using the man as a
quote-unquote punching bag for your
feelings he's going to say something
but you can't say
why would you say that because it's like
they're saying it because you're on the
receiving end of the feelings
that's why that's all
okay